CHRIS DEFAY: I am Chris
DeFay, a member of the Authors
at Google Team here in Venice--
our Venice, Los Angeles office.
And I'm pleased to welcome our
guest Olga Oliker who joins us
from the Rand Corporation.
Ms. Oliker's based in
Rand's Washington office
where she is Associate Director
of International Security
and Defense Policy Center and
a senior international policy
analyst.
Her research is focused on
international relations,
national security policy,
and a context of countries
in conflict, post-conflict,
transition, development,
and reform.
Her research
examines these issues
in Russia, Central Asia, the
Caucasus, Iraq, Afghanistan,
and other countries.
She joins us today for
a timely discussion
of recent developments
in Ukraine and Russia.
The title of her talk is
"Russia-- What Happened,
What's Next."
Please join me in
welcoming Olga Oliker.
Thank you.
OLGA OLIKER: Thanks everybody--
thanks for coming out.
It's really a
pleasure to be here.
So I've been asked
to talk to you today
about Russia, Ukraine--
what's going on,
what it means for
the United States.
And if you do tend to follow
US-Russia relations-- things
like that.
What you've probably
noticed, even
without paying too
much attention,
is that our relationship
has shifted from, kind of,
this one of general tension--
a lot of cooperation--
didn't seem that bad-- to
what seems like a stand off.
And all of this,
seemingly, because
of this little peninsula
in the Black Sea.
So how did we get here?
And where do we go now?
What I'm going to
do today is I'm
going to break this down
into four components--
talk about each of them.
And then, actually, I hope
to have a good bit of time
to hear what you all think and
to talk about it a little bit.
So first I'm going to talk
about Ukraine-- Crimea-- what
that's all about.
Then I'd like to
turn, a little bit,
to what's happening in
Russia domestically,
and what has happened
over the last few years.
Third, move back
to Ukraine and what
this means in the context
of Russian relations
with the United States.
And then, finally, you
know, my crystal ball
has been really in bad shape
throughout this entire crisis.
I'm not going to
make any predictions,
but I can talk a
little bit about what
it means going forward.
So first of all, what
happened in Ukraine?
And there's a map over there.
Here's Ukraine,
here's Crimea, here's
Russia-- I'm don't know if it's
a point-- a political point
that Russia doesn't get a label.
I've noticed that you have to,
like, kind of, get most of it
on before it starts
getting labeled.
And it's so big--
it's hard to do.
So the way I like
to talk about what's
happened in the last
few months in Ukraine
is there are several
different stories
you can tell about it-- several
kinds of truths-- several kinds
of narratives.
So one story that
you may have heard
is that late last fall-- this
past fall the people of Ukraine
took to the streets to protest
a corrupt autocratic leader who
had turned his back on
an association agreement
with the European Union.
And instead, decided
to ink a deal
with Russia to bail
out Ukraine's disaster
of an economy.
These people who came out to
the streets demanded his ouster.
He had his police force
fire on peaceful protesters.
And then he fled the country.
The parliament of
Ukraine was forced
to put in an interim government
to rule until elections could
be held, and they're
scheduled for May.
But Russia, then
went and paid people
to cross into Ukraine to
protest the new government
and use that as a
pretext to grab control
the Crimean peninsula.
And it's now fomenting
unrest elsewhere in Ukraine--
potentially, in order to invade.
So that's one story.
Here's another story.
A mob came onto the
streets to demand
the ouster of a democratically
elected leader in Ukraine who
had made a choice to
work with Russia to save
a country in dire
economic straits
at a time when
association with the EU
would have led to further
austerity and hardship
for large chunks
of the population.
That mob, egged on by the United
States and European Union,
which were helping finance
them, included a variety
of right-wing ultra
nationalist groups.
And they threw Molotov
cocktails at police.
They took police
officers hostage,
and they engaged in a
variety of violent activity.
The parliament then took
a series of illegal votes.
One of them being to oust
the democratically elected
president and then
appointed a parliament that
has no legitimacy because
they just-- sorry--
appointed a government that has
no legitimacy because, well, it
was just appointed
by Parliament.
Nobody elected them.
And as a result of this, there
has been chaos in Ukraine--
throughout the countries.
And right-winged militias
have roamed the streets
and been allowed to, kind
of, patrol and bring order.
In Crimea, where
there's a majority
ethnic Russian population,
these people-- terrified of both
the fascists and the prospect
of future discrimination because
of cultural nationalists,
voted to secede from Ukraine
and then chose to join Russia.
In other parts of the
country, ethnic Russians
and Russian speakers
are rising up
against this
illegitimate government
and seeking Russian
help and protection.
So these aren't the only
two stories out there.
You can tell other
stories, but they
are two of the most
important-- thank you.
And they're part-- they are two
of most important because, as I
think, you might have noticed
the first one is, kind of, one
you hear from a lot
of Western outlets.
And the second is one
that you hear from one
a lot of Russian outlets.
And the Russian outlets
include Russian television,
which broadcasts into
eastern and southern Ukraine
where a lot of folks who are
ethnically Russian or Ukrainian
speak Russian as
their first language.
And indeed, there's
nobody in Ukraine
who doesn't speak some
Russian and some Ukrainian.
It's not as though,
you know, there
are people who speak
just one or the other.
And the problem is that neither
story is all true or all false.
Yanukovych was
incredibly corrupt.
But then so have been
every government in Ukraine
since independence.
He was also
democratically elected.
There are other-- there are, in
fact, ultra right wing groups,
in the new government.
But they're far from most of it.
And the interim government
is trying to get control over
the militia's.
And they've taken legal action.
And, in fact, the police shot
one of the militia leaders
recently-- and under
questionable or-- according
to the police he shot
himself twice in the chest,
so-- while resisting arrest.
So, you know, there's that.
Some of the protesters in
southern and eastern Ukraine,
probably are paid, or at
least, reimbursed by Russia.
And some of them may
be coming from Russia.
But that's not all of them.
And there are enough familial
ties between Russia and Ukraine
that there's an argument to
be made that these people do--
they-- some of them
do have a voice.
Some of them probably
are coming to Moscow
and have no relationship.
And there is real
nervousness and discontent
in these regions.
I'm not saying it's
prevalent, but there
are people who are nervous.
The other problem
is that even if you
choose to believe one story
and dismiss the other one,
the fact is that other people in
the US, in Russia, in Germany,
and Poland, and
in Ukraine believe
the one you don't believe.
And they act accordingly.
So for instance, economic
analyses might indicate,
and kind of does, that the
austerian measures called
for by the EU and
IMF won't actually
be that bad for Ukrainians.
Particularly, if
they're instituted now.
It's warm.
You don't need that much gas.
All these gas subsidies
aren't as big an issue.
But if Ukrainians in
the south and the east
don't believe that-- if they
think that this is really
going to hurt them, they're
still going to oppose it.
They're still not going
to want it to take place.
And it's a question of will they
believe the economist you trot
out as opposed to the economist
that somebody else trots out.
So that's Ukraine, and
we'll come back to it.
But I'd like to, also,
briefly talk about Russia--
where the annexation of
Crimea is stunningly popular.
Especially if you consider
that a month and a half ago
nobody in Russia was thinking
about annexing Crimea at all.
But since approval ratings
are through the roof--
and just as Russia
was consolidating
control of Crimea.
If you were paying
attention you might also
notice that the Russian
government's shutting down
a few more bits of what was
left of the opposition media.
Which has kind of
been a steady process,
but right around the time of
the Crimea thing, the editor
of the news site [INAUDIBLE]
which-- you know,
it was a very good news site.
I used it all the time-- was
fired because she had allowed
for the publication of
an interview with one
of the Ukraine far
right leaders, actually.
And then her-- the majority
of editorial staff resigned.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
was effectively
gone-- though they've, kind of,
reconstitute themselves a bit.
Now Russian new
media was already
pretty tightly controlled.
And most people in
Russia don't mind, right?
They're fine getting their
news from the Kremlin approved
a television stations.
So where the opposition
media mostly works
is-- they're preaching
to the choir.
They're talking
to people who are
looking for that
sort of information.
So shutting them
down is-- it's kind
of a bit of insult to injury.
It's basically saying, yeah, we
know no one's listening to you,
but we don't want you
to have access anyway.
And it's, kind of,
also worth noting
that as of today
Voice of America,
the US funded-- actually US
funded-- it's a US Government
agency-- broadcasts in
Russia have been told
their license wasn't
going to be renewed.
And they're no longer going
to get their little AM
band to broadcast on.
The political
opposition in Russia
hit its height a couple of
years ago-- winter 2011.
Kind of on the eve of the
March 2012 election that
brought Vladimir
Putin back to power.
Tens of thousands of,
mostly, middle class Russians
came out to the
streets, because they
weren't real happy
with the fact that
didn't have a real choice in
this presidential election.
That they felt that
this wasn't real.
That this wasn't right.
Putin still won.
And he probably
would have won-- you
know there are talks about
how the election was doctored
da, da, da.
He would have won.
It wasn't that he
wasn't popular.
But he was nervous
as a result of this.
He looked out at all these
people who he thought about as,
you know, all their wealth,
their comfort, their ability
to go to sushi bars
and coffee shops--
that was because of him.
He was the one who had
presided over a decade
of strong economic
growth for Russia.
He was the reason there
was a middle class.
And what is with this, you
know, why aren't they grateful.
Why are they, instead, coming
on to the streets demanding
his oust-- well not
have been his ouster,
but demanding choice--
demanding that somebody else be
able to run.
Mm, oh well, we've lost our map.
MALE VOICE: I'll
bring it up for you.
OLGA OLIKER: OK-- so,
because he was nervous,
he instituted this campaign
against the opposition.
And it's kind of
been a-- there's
been a slow, but steady,
process of arrest, harassment,
significant limits on what
the opposition can do.
For instance, if you read in
the papers about a protest
with 50,000 people in Russia,
what you don't, necessarily,
read is that in order to
get their permit to protest
they have to say exactly
where they're going to be.
It's, kind of, closed off.
The only people who
show up are the people
who've shown up to protest.
So it's not as though
you're, kind of,
in the middle of the
street and anybody
can come by and watch
and listen and join.
It's really-- these are the
people who know about it
and who can show up.
And in the mean
time-- the other thing
that Putin's nervousness
has led him to
is he's making his
decisions speaking
to fewer and fewer people.
This is something that
everybody who watched this
agrees that he's not
listening to a broad range.
His Foreign Minister
probably doesn't
have a lot of influence over
what it is Putin decides to do.
And you can see this, for
instance, in this crisis where
you had other Russian
officials saying,
Russia will, of course,
respect Ukraine sovereignty.
We have no intention
of doing anything.
Oh, hey look, we took
Crimea-- that's-- um-- yeah.
You know, it's because
nobody told them.
We have-- even have
every reason to think
that he's flying by
the seat of his pants
on some things-- including this.
But we also have no
way to influence it,
and it's dangerous.
Because what he's doing
is he's closing himself
off to a very real
debate that does go on
that you do-- you
can hear, and you
can access amongst
Russian thought leaders.
But he is not listening to them.
So the bottom line is you
have an incredibly popular
Russian president
making decisions
without broad consultation
and in opposition
that's fragmented and weak.
At the same time,
you have a knowledge
that there is a core
of dissatisfaction.
You know, it's not surprising
that opinion ratings are really
high right now.
If you look at the opinion
ratings for George Bush
right after the
invasion of Iraq.
They were very high, as well.
It's, you know, people tend
to rally around the flag
when these things happen.
So the knowledge that tens
of thousands of people did
come out onto the
streets in winter 2011--
and it's cold in
winter in Russia.
And coming out into the streets
to protest in winter-- Ukraine,
too-- I can-- that
is saying something.
That means that there
is something there
that could be harnessed
and could respond, even
with all the propaganda.
So let's turn back to Ukraine
and the US-Russia relationship.
The US-- its European
allies responded
to an annexation of Crimea
about as you'd expect.
They said that it was illegal.
They said it was improper.
They had put
sanctions on Russia.
And, you know, indeed
it's pretty illegal.
And not only is it illegal--
and it's illegal in part
because you don't
violate sovereignty.
And this has been Russia's
big soapbox for years--
that sovereignty is important.
So it's a little odd.
And then, Russia also signed
the Budapest Agreement back
in the early '90s, committing
to Ukraine sovereignty,
very specifically.
So, you know, it's
pretty illegal.
But the US and
Europe haven't said,
we're, therefore, going to
take up arms against you.
They've said, we're
going to sanction.
We're very unhappy.
This makes us rethink
our relationship.
And, of course, as Putin made
clear in a speech on March 18th
when he did talk about the
annexation of Crimea and did
try to justify it and say
that it was, in fact, legal.
This isn't, really,
just about Ukraine.
That's the red in the Russian
narrative about Western support
for the activists that
overthrew Yanukovych
is an important
thing to remember.
Because from
Russia's prospective,
what happened in Ukraine
over the last few months--
just like what happened
in Ukraine in 2004
with the Orange Revolution
and what happened in Georgia
in 2003 with the Rose
revolution, and indeed,
the opposition protests in
Russia a few years ago--
these are foreign funded
efforts to weaken Russia.
To prevent it's exercising
it's natural influence
on countries on its periphery.
And to, kind of, grow in
global influence, as well.
And thinking about these
countries on it's periphery,
you have to remember it's
not just that they were part
of the Soviet Union--
these countries are
part of Russian empire.
Russia hasn't bought into
the notion that these
are countries, and in the
case of Russia itself,
people making
independent choices.
The way Russia sees this is it's
in competition with the United
States for influence and
control in these areas.
And this isn't a
Putin thing, right?
This-- you know,
you'll hear people
say, oh, it's Vladimir Putin.
And some of it is.
But this part isn't.
You can go back to
the Yeltsin era.
You can go back to '92-'
93, and everywhere--
every Russian
strategy document--
threat of NATO enlargement, the
need to protect ethnic Russians
outside Russia, and how
important the neighborhood is
to Russia.
They're there-- again
and again and again.
And Ukraine, particularly,
is very central
because as Putin
indicated in his speech,
the histories of
Russia and Ukraine
are incredibly intertwined.
And they're intertwined in ways
that, not that surprisingly,
are viewed differently
from the two countries.
Again, you have
different stories.
For Russia, Ukraine was
always, for the most part,
you know-- kind of different
borders at different times--
but Ukraine's part of Russia.
And it's Russia's hinterlands.
It's the provinces.
It's not-- kind of, it's
not a separate country
with links to Russia.
It's part of Russia.
Russians think of the
Ukrainian language
as a form of Russian
spoken by people
who don't speak
Russian that well.
And for Ukraine--
for Ukrainians--
Ukraine had proud
indepenitration.
OK, so it hasn't been
an independent state
for very long.
And before that, it was
an independent state
for a very brief period in the
middle of a World War once.
But they are a people.
They are a nation.
They have a language.
And they've been
oppressed by the Russians,
even if they do come from
many of the same roots.
Which some Ukrainian
nationalists question,
but I think
linguistically that's
a tougher one to counter.
But what this means
is the possibility
of loss of influence in other
post-Soviet states is bad.
The possibility of not having
sway over Ukraine is anathema.
It's just-- it's crazy.
It doesn't make sense.
So for Russia it's
about Ukraine,
which is really important.
And it's about the United
States and fighting the US
for influence in
it's neighborhood.
And then what?
Because that's one
of the questions
I think we're grappling with.
It is, kind of,
just about Ukraine.
Is it just about
the neighborhood?
Or is this part
of Putin's effort
to build up a global
role for Russia?
Sometimes in cooperation
with this US--
sometimes in opposition.
But we have seen Russia playing
more and more of a role.
So is this Russia
flexing its muscles?
And if it is, what's
it going to do
with them after
it's flexed them?
Which is one of the
things that I think has,
you know, what has
shocked people.
What has confused
people about Crimea,
specifically, is that
before these events
of the last few weeks,
the general view
was that Russia wanted influence
in the region, not territory.
But it's just taken territory.
And it's put troops
near Ukraine's border--
and walk them back
and put them back.
And there are troops that
are stationed there normally,
and dah, dah, dah, dah.
But, you know, some stuff moved.
And then there are the
protests in Ukraine.
And there is clear evidence that
Russians are involved in them.
And then Putin's really
nationalistic speech
about Crimea.
You start wondering,
maybe, he does want more.
And you're seeing this debated.
And if they do want more--
do they want Ukraine?
Do they want Transnistria
and then, Moldova?
Or does it go further?
And for the US and for its
European allies in NATO-- well
they don't want
Russia to go further.
It's not because
of Ukraine itself.
They don't-- this
may sound harsh,
but they don't actually care
about Ukraine specifically.
They care about the principal.
They're worried
about the possibility
that it means more than Ukraine.
But where Ukraine
is concerned, they
have no alliance
commitments to Ukraine.
They have no promises
to protect it.
This is annoying and a
bummer and difficult.
But if it's just
Ukraine, it means
something very different from
if it's broader than Ukraine.
Particularly if it actually
does hit NATO's borders.
Because that's where you do
have alliance commitments.
And of course Poles, Romanians,
and the Baltic states--
who are the closest and who are
the ones that might have reason
to think that Russia has designs
on them, get really nervous.
And then we get really nervous.
Because these are allies.
We do have commitments to them.
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
is everybody there,
like along the Russian border
in NATO except Ukraine?
These [INAUDIBLE].
OLGA OLIKER: Um--
these guys are in NATO.
NATO-- NATO-- so Belarus
isn't, Ukraine isn't, Moldova
isn't, Georgia [INAUDIBLE] that
we're getting out of Europe
aren't.
But the Rumanian's
are-- so you're
kind of NATO-Europe over here.
Non-NATO-Europe over there.
And one of things
I've been watching
over the last few years is
how the definition of Central
and Eastern Europe has shifted,
over the last 20 years.
Right?
Because it used to be that
this was Central Europe.
Now this is Central Europe.
And, you know, people seem
to argue about whether or not
Russia is Europe,
geographically.
You know, the Ural
Mountains in Europe.
But, you know, there
is also the confusion.
So is Eastern Europe,
now, just Russia
is also-- it's a fascinating
question of linguistics.
And the problem with
this is that if you
are talking about some
sort of military conflict
with Russia-- well
the nuclear shadow
hangs over any military
conflict with Russia.
And this makes everybody
pretty nervous.
Not that they actually think
nuclear war's going to happen.
But, you know what,
no one actually
thought that Russia was
going to annex Crimea either.
So where do we go from here?
I think there's no question
that what's happened
changes the nature of US and
European relations with Russia.
But to what extent
depends largely
on what Russia does next.
There are a lot of
people who would
blame the US for these events.
I mean, you hear a lot of
things of did we get this wrong?
How did we get this wrong?
But you know, it's not
particularly clear to me
that I can point
to a policy that we
could have had over the last 20
years that would have gotten us
somewhere else.
You know some people-- and just
to, kind of, underline this,
Thomas Friedman has a piece
in today's New York Times
that says that we were too hard
on the Russians in the early
'90s-- shouldn't have
pushed NATO enlargement.
Other people say we weren't
hard enough on the Russians.
We didn't demonstrate to them
how important this stuff was.
We should have let
Ukraine into NATO.
So you hear both
of these things.
But the fact of the matter
is, Russian positions on this
were always pretty clear.
That this is their neighborhood.
This is their
sphere of influence
and beyond that-- unclear.
And while Washington-- what
Washington and Brussels were
trying to do during this
period was help-- kind of,
help create the conditions where
Russia would get to a point
where the independence
of its neighbors
didn't feel threatening to it.
That it was integrated into
the community of nations.
That it had more to lose than
to gain from action like this.
And I think they thought
they'd, kind of, gotten there.
But they turned out to be wrong.
That doesn't mean that there
was an obvious better solution.
It just means that
it didn't work out
quite the way people hoped.
So I would say that
if Russia doesn't
take any further
military action,
we're in for a long
and difficult period.
Not a Cold War.
The Cold War, some
of you may remember,
was two countries that were
juxtaposed against each other.
And everything they
did was informed
by how the other would respond.
Everything they did
was partly geared
to how the other would respond.
The United States
couldn't care less
what Russia thinks on most
of it's policies anywhere.
Russia cares what the
United States thinks.
But the United States doesn't.
And this doesn't change that.
Because there's no
particular reason for it to.
Russia just isn't that
important to us globally.
As the president said,
it's a regional power
not a global power.
The problem is the
region's Europe.
And we care a lot about Europe.
But that's an aside.
But it's going to be tense.
And Russia might
behave a little bit
as though it's a
Cold War situation.
And it has long looked
for opportunities
to tweak the United
States where it could.
And that's not going to stop.
And it's going to be difficult.
And for Ukraine,
itself, it's going
to be-- continue to be mess.
And the lead up to
these elections--
Ukraine gets-- if
Ukraine manages
to get to have these
elections, there's
going to be a lot of
effort to keep it chaotic.
To influence the
election process.
And what the Russians
are pushing for now
is, basically, for them
and the United States
to sit down at a table and
write Ukraine a constitution
and force it on Ukraine.
And their argument is that
the interim government
isn't legitimate, so they
can't be part of this.
The US and Europe push back and
say, Ukraine must be involved.
We're going to just
keep seeing this.
And it's going to be messy.
And it's going to be ugly.
And it's going to be very
difficult for Ukraine.
And then for us, and
for the Europeans,
kind of, staying the course
through a difficult process
is going to be hard.
Because there are two camps,
I would say, in both the US
and in NATO Europe, which
have two very opposite lines
of thought that both
kind of dangerous.
One is nostalgia for
the status quo of,
I don't know, say,
last summer where
things were OK with Russia.
And the idea is that,
OK, fine, so we give them
whatever they want in Ukraine.
And then we can start
moving the gas back.
And we don't have
to impose sanctions
that are inconvenient
for us, too.
And we can just go
back to where it was,
because we liked
it the way it was.
And then the other
is the people who's
nostalgia goes further back.
Who really are nostalgic for the
Cold War, and who would like,
kind of, a nice clear enemy.
And who'd like to make
it all about Russia,
and all about beating Russia
down and punishing Russia.
And how many other
ways can we find
to make things worse for Russia?
Which will not,
in the long term,
really advance a lot of US
goals for European security.
So that's what I think happens.
So I think, kind of, bouncing
between these two things
and having a very long
and difficult process
of coordinating
policies-- what happens
if we stay at this stalemate.
If Russia does take
military action-- well,
I actually think what happens if
Russia takes military action is
it's going to find that this
is pretty self defeating.
Russian forces are fighting
their Ukrainian brothers.
I'm not sure how well that plays
in the Kharkov and Habaroff's,
and for that matter,
Moscow and St. Petersburg.
And it will-- this
won't be Crimea.
East and Southern Ukraine
are very different.
Most people they
aren't ethnic Russians.
Even of those who are--
and IRI poll just released
found that about 2/3 of the
ethnic Russians in Ukraine
don't feel particularly
under threat.
In fact, fewer than 30%
do think that there's
anything threat at all to them.
Most Southern and Eastern
Ukrainians-- again,
well over 60%-- have
no desire, whatsoever,
for Russian military
troops in their region
or in their country.
So if Russia takes
military action in Ukraine,
it's not sanctions from
Europe and the United States
that are going to punish them.
It's the effects of doing this.
And there are definitely those
in Russia who recognize this.
Question is whether Putin
and his inner circle do.
And whether-- and
the other question
is whether Russian traditional
views of Ukraine and, kind of,
this inability to recognize
Ukraine as separate
will undermine
rationality, in this case.
So I'm going to
stop there, and I
want to hear you all
think and discuss this.
CHRIS DEFAY: OK, so we're
happy to take questions,
but let's please pass the
mic to the person who's
going to do the question.
And you're right here,
so, first question.
AUDIENCE: Hi--
CHRIS DEFAY: Should be on.
AUDIENCE: Hi, hello--
CHRIS DEFAY: Uh,
it's working even
though it's not [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK, sorry.
OK, so one thing that
I-- like for example,
when I hear this discussions,
one thing that I think is lost
is the fact that
people in Crimea
actually voted to be,
like, attached to Russia.
So well, I don't-- I
know how-- I'm Iranian,
so I know how governments can
manipulate views and change
the way that people
see the news.
But I think, like,
it says something
when most of the people
in that peninsula
voted to actually be
attached to Russia.
And where I read the
news, and I see, like,
two or three other
cities, [INAUDIBLE]--
when I hear that-- again, there
are some Pro-Russian groups
of people that actually
want to attach to Russia.
So I think, like-- and I've
heard from one of my friends
that are, actually, two
groups of people in Ukraine,
not related to US or Russia
who, actually, some of them,
want to-- like they're
Pro-Russian, and some or not.
So I think it's more about
what Ukrainian people think
than what US wants there
or what Russia wants there.
OLGA OLIKER: OK,
AUDIENCE: So
OLGA OLIKER: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, and the
people who voted-- yeah,
there are some people who
came from Russia to protest,
but I think the people who voted
were actually Ukrainians that--
like--
OLGA OLIKER: OK--
so Crimea is weird.
I will-- Crimea is about
60% ethnically Russian.
Crimea also has a
population of about 25%
of a indigenous
population-- or fairly,
indigenous you know indigenous
varies year to year.
MALE VOICE: As
indigenous as it gets.
OLGA OLIKER: Yes-- called
the Crimean Tatars,
who were expelled
from their home region
after World War II by Stalin.
Forced you to
Uzbekistan-- lots of them
died along the way-- weren't
allowed to come back.
[INAUDIBLE] allowed to
come back until the 1980s.
Those people boycotted
the referendum.
So the Crimean Tatars are very
nervous about the possibility
of Russian rule, as
a people and felt
that the referendum was
not valid and not something
that was going to respond.
Now, beyond that,
there is this question
of how do countries-- how do
pieces of countries secede?
When the Soviet
Union fell apart,
the Soviet
constitution, actually,
had laid out very clearly
how Republics could secede.
And they all,
actually, did that.
They followed these
rules-- including Ukraine.
Ukraine's constitution
didn't really have this.
But generally speaking,
there is a thing-- you know,
countries have borders.
And, generally
speaking, there are
bits of countries that
are unhappy with that.
And there are
movements to secede.
And sometimes, eventually,
that happens over time.
You've got Scotland doing that.
But in Crimea that's
not what you had.
It's not as though Crimeans,
last year, were thinking, gosh,
it would be nice
to rejoin Russia.
It is very much a product of
what happened in the last two
months, and the Russian news
media and the propaganda
campaign, that created
this environment.
So there's a reason that
these processes are usually
time consuming.
There's a long lead up.
There's a lot of discussion.
You didn't have any of that.
This was kind of--
this was very sudden.
And then-- this is even just
taking out of the equation
82% of Crimeans voted
with 97% percent of them.
We know 82% of
Crimeans didn't vote,
because we know that the Crimean
Tatars boycotted the election.
So-- and I'm really-- 97%?
So there's a lot of question
about whether the referendum
is, in any way, valid.
So, you know, just-- yes,
self determination is great.
But self determination
is usually
pretty well controlled globally.
And in this particular
case there's
a lot of reason
to wonder just how
self-determined it really was.
AUDIENCE: So you
started your talk
with describing two different
views of what's going on.
And, of course,
when people disagree
or two countries disagrees,
there's always two views.
Each are not exactly the same.
I think the question
that I have is
in your opinion,
which of those views
have more legitimacy
or more aligned
is reality-- for some
definition of reality.
OLGA OLIKER: I'd
rather not take one.
I mean I'd actually-- I think
that to understand what's
going on, you have to understand
that these are the views.
Because they drive
how people think.
And then, you can draw
your own conclusions
about what's really going on.
And I would argue-- you know,
sorry, that was kind of,
postmodernist, but, my
views, too-- they're
based on who I believe; who I
don't believe; who I listen to;
who I don't; what
news sources I trust;
which news sources
I don't trust.
So, kind of, when I ran through
this-- that, yes, of course
he was corrupt, but he was
also democratically elected.
I don't think that
protests are a great way
to change governments.
You know, sometimes it happens,
but over all, that's not a sign
that you have a
healthy democracy.
It's a sign that you're
still working towards it.
And if you keep having
protests to change governments,
that's, also-- that's not good.
I think the parliament's choice
to oust Yanukovych and put
in a new government was a
questionable legality, though.
I've heard another
story line that
says that the fact Yanukovych's
own party voted for this-- was
actually their way of subverting
the process to make sure
it wasn't legitimate, so
that it would continue.
So conspiracy
theories everywhere.
But I also think the Russians
are fomenting unrest.
And I also think that there is
a real danger from right wing
groups in Ukraine's government.
And I also think Ukraine
needs to develop-- if Ukraine
is going to succeed, it's
going to be better off
with economic reform.
Which probably won't hurt
as much people think.
And that it's going to
need to be economic reform
and political reform
that encompasses
the whole country, including
the East and South.
It can't ignore the interests
and concerns of these people.
So my views of--
my view is you have
to take a little from column
A, a little from column B,
and then a few things from
just a few other places
to put together a truer story.
But I also recognize that
all histories, at least,
somewhat biased.
AUDIENCE: But do
you have a storyline
which you think is more correct?
Even though you don't
want to reveal it, or--
OLGA OLIKER: Well I think
I told you my story.
No, I think I just tried
to tell you my story line.
MALE VOICE: We'll go down here.
AUDIENCE: My question
is about the Gazprom.
So what's your-- think of
the prospect of Gazprom,
or on this geopolitical tension?
Gazprom, the
company, in the sense
of will it make a lot
of money off of this?
Or will it lose a lot of money.
Or will the sanctions
hurt it at all.
AUDIENCE: The prospect that we
have it to be not [INAUDIBLE]
or national lines [INAUDIBLE].
OLGA OLIKER: You know,
the joke about Gazprom
is that it's not always clear
whether it's that Gazprom has
influence over the Russian
government or vice versa.
It's talking about
nationalization-- Gazprom
ignores, kind of, the very
tight links between Gazprom
and the government.
I don't think they
need to nationalize it.
I don't think they have any--
AUDIENCE: Gazprom
might privatize
the Russian government.
OLGA OLIKER: Gazprom
could privatize
the Russian Government,
potentially.
You know, I think over time,
if the Europeans do shift away
from Russian gas, that will
not be good for Gazprom.
If Ukraine-- which Ukraine
really needs to do is
institute some
energy efficiency.
I mean even a few, just,
moves towards a metering
and being a little more
efficient with their use
of energy, and they'd
be supplying themselves.
They won't need Russia at all.
And that would also
hurt Gazprom-- even
with all these reduced rates.
But, yeah, the thing that
hurts the Russian gas industry,
in the long term, is failure
to invest in infrastructure
over time and continue to
rely on a lot of, really,
old infrastructure.
And, kind of, looking for
new routes and new customers,
rather than thinking about
ways to do things better.
So overall, yes, if
this goes forward,
Gazprom won't be in good shape.
But there's still a
lot of Russian gas.
And people will still buy it.
So I don't think it's
the end of the world.
I think where Gazprom
runs into trouble
over time is failure to invest.
AUDIENCE: China's been
surprisingly reticent
in all this.
You would think given
Tibet, for instance,
they would be rather opposed
to redrawing borders.
But what is your take
about the long term
interest of China
in this conflict?
OLGA OLIKER: So given,
yeah, given Tibet they'd
be opposed to redrawing borders.
Given Taiwan, and all those
islands, they might be for it.
Kind of like Russia,
and, actually, kind of
like everybody.
You know, there's--
your interests vary,
depending on a particular piece
of geography are looking at.
I've heard different things
come out of different people's
conversations with Chinese
officials and Chinese analysts.
One view is that their
abstention in the UN
means that they've
got Russia's back.
I've never quite heard
of those tensions
meaning you have somebody's
back before, but OK.
Another is that they are quite
nervous because of Tibet.
And they are-- they
don't like this.
Russia and China have had
a very odd relationship
over the last-- well,
over a long time,
you know, from the Soviet Union.
But if we just look at
Russia-- independent Russia--
that on the one
hand, they cooperate
and coordinate a
lot, because they do
you have a lot of shared views.
One of the shared views
has, traditionally,
been about the importance
of sovereignty though,
so this is a little difficult.
But they also really
distrust one another
and have consistently.
So it's always been a
very fraught relationship.
And if you look at how
Russian's view China,
there's, kind of, a split there.
People who think that China is
Russia's most important ally.
And there are people who
think the Chinese are just
biding their time
until they decide
to grab a big chunk
of Russia's far east.
And in China it's a little
more difficult to parse this.
But I think you have similar
split between those who think
that Russia is a good
partner, and those who don't.
So this is not a great
answer, because it's
an I don't know answer.
But I think, in general, the
Chinese are nervous about this,
and they're going to
watch how it plays out.
AUDIENCE: Given the
strategic importance
of Crimea and the, largely,
Russian population--
looking back to when the
Soviet Union was falling apart,
and the borders were getting
drawn how did it end up
part of the Ukraine
instead of Russia anyway?
OLGA OLIKER: OK-- could
we get the map back?
So I think-- first
of all, I think
the strategic importance
of Crimea is overstated.
It was extremely
strategically important
during the Crimean War--
which was a while ago.
But if you-- if
we look at the map
MALE VOICE: Google, itself,
has a very nice map.
[INAUDIBLE]
OLGA OLIKER: This is a Google--
MALE VOICE: [INAUDIBLE].
OLGA OLIKER: This
is Google Maps.
And we can zoom into Crimea.
Let's go to Crimea.
And let's go to the
whole Black Sea.
Can this get-- I want to get
the whole Black Sea in-- OK,
right-- thank you.
And then we need to
get it on this frame.
MALE VOICE: OK.
OLGA OLIKER: OK-- so
this is the Black Sea.
To get out of the Black Sea,
you got to go through here.
It's pretty closed off.
So you hear a lot about how
Russia has kept its Black Sea
fleet here.
It's very important.
And the fleet is based
in Sevastopal here.
And, indeed, it's a nice port.
It's-- you've got good
access and so forth.
But Russia--
Russia's been hedging
against the loss of-- access
to Crimea for a long time.
The way it's continued to have
it's Black Sea fleet there
is it's kept signing
these leases with Ukraine
over and over again.
And Ukrainian
governments, even ones
that were ostensibly
Western leaning,
have agreed to keep it there.
But they knew that this
might not last forever.
So they've, actually,
for the last few years,
been building up facilities
in the [INAUDIBLE] here.
Which isn't as handy, right?
You can't have quite as
much space around it,
but it's not bad.
And it's doable.
So that's one piece of it.
And this is-- this
is purely military.
It's not like there's
a lot of trade
going in and out of Sevastopal.
So the other thing
that I would point out
is the Black Sea fleet is the
smallest of Russia's fleets.
And it's not in great shape.
So it's not as though-- unless
you count the Caspian Flotilla,
which is also in the Black Sea.
So it's not as though Russia
was putting a lot of resources
and energy into keeping this
there for strategic reasons.
I mean, kind of, if
you look at a map,
you wonder to do
what exactly that it
couldn't do some other way.
Or from the [INAUDIBLE]
if it needed to.
So then, the history-- in
1954-- for a long time, Crimea,
in the Soviet Union,
was, actually, autonomous
and didn't belong to anybody.
And then, it belonged to Russia.
And then in 1954,
Khrushchev as Premier,
decided to give it
as a brotherly gift
to the Ukrainian
people-- thinking
that this meant,
pretty much, nothing.
Because all the Ukraine had a
vote at the UN and so forth.
It was part of the Soviet
Union, just like Russia,
so this was, kind of,
a meaningless gesture
of something.
And there's a lot of debate
as to what he was thinking.
And you can find lots
of different stories.
And nobody really knows.
In 1991-92, when the Soviet
Union was splitting up,
a lot of people assumed that
Russia would take Crimea back.
Because the Black Sea fleet
was there, it would be easier.
It just seemed-- you
know, they didn't.
I, for one, was
surprised at the time.
I thought that they would.
And I think a lot of it had
to do with just weakness--
trying to get this done,
trying to draw the borders.
Fine, we got it.
You want your own country.
Here it is.
There were there all
sorts of deals, initially,
for the fleet-- that
Ukraine and Russia
would both hold onto the fleet.
And then Russia
held onto the fleet.
So I think, in many ways,
it's an accident of history.
But it's an accident of history
that wasn't that important.
And I would argue it's
still not important.
It's still important,
now, more as an accident
and an opportunity, than
because of Crimea, itself,
being important.
AUDIENCE: And how much does
the rest of the Ukraine care
about Crimea.
I mean, I've seen very little
protests on the streets of Kiev
about losing Crimea.
And I could even imagine that
a lot of Pro-Western people
in the Ukraine are,
almost, happy to get rid
of this Russian stronghold.
OLGA OLIKER: No,
I think Ukrainians
are pretty pissed off
about the loss of Crimea.
The same-- the IRI poll found
that the vast majority of them
did not think that--
and by vast majority,
I mean well into the
80th percentiles--
did not think that
this was the--
that the referendum was valid.
Don't think that the
Russian action was valid.
They are angry.
They can't do an awful
lot about it, right?
And it terrifies them.
Because they're
terrified the Russians
are going to move
into more of Ukraine.
But, yeah, I wouldn't say they
were eager to lose Crimea.
AUDIENCE: OK, so I
have two questions.
The first is about Crimea's
status within Russia.
OLGA OLIKER: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: So is it going
to be an autonomous
state within Russia?
And particularly, what's going
to happen the minorities there
who sum up 40% of
the population.
Particularly, Ukrainians--
using their language, et cetera.
So what's the foreseeable
future by that?
That's one.
The other is this
whole operation
seems to be very professional
done by the Russians,
unlike their
previous operations--
military operations and,
also, the elections.
So it's really hard to
believe that this just
happened all of sudden.
Do we have any data about
Russia's planning this-- maybe
for years?
OLGA OLIKER: So
Crimea's status--
Crimea has, historically,
been autonomous
wherever it's been and
had a lot of autonomy.
And the reason for
that was primarily--
or the excuse for
it was the Tatars,
as the indigenous,
I think, population.
That, kind of, they should have
their own state-- their own--
or stateling.
I think how Russia treats
Crimea is a great question.
And I'm-- to be really
honest with you,
I'm more nervous about
the Tatars than I am about
to the Ukrainian population.
Because they have such a
history of being oppressed.
And because, right now--
still people who had came back
are not living under
the best of conditions.
There are still questions
about their access
to land and housing.
So since Russia came in to
protect people's human rights--
and I would say it's
a very important test
of what that means.
How they treat both the
Ukrainian population
and the Tatar population.
Then the military-- the
Russian military-- first,
I would say that military's
plan for all sorts of things.
And they have tons of plans
on the books for everything.
Just because they have a
plan, means nothing about what
they're actually
intending to do or not.
So do they have some
sort of plan for Crimea?
Maybe.
Was it this?
I think, probably,
aspects of it.
Because what you actually do
when you implement these plans,
is you take something from
here and something from there
and you pull them together.
Because the actual situation
is never quite what
you expect it to be.
I don't think of Crimea as
a military operation though.
I think of it as a
political operation
which was backed by force.
But it's not as though Russian
armed forces were called on
to do an awful lot--
other than stand around
with guns in unmarked uniforms
looking, kind of, mean.
So it's not as though
they faced any-- it's not
as though they faced,
really, opposition.
It's the Ukrainians
were trying very hard
not to provoke anything.
So they didn't,
particularly, fight back.
So it's not like
it's a-- I think
it's a great
propaganda operation.
I think it's a really
impressive political operation.
But I don't think it
tells me much about how
the Russian military
does, other than the fact
that it can send people
who will follow orders.
And I knew that it
could do that before,
particularly, with
the elite forces.
And honestly, from
Georgia I knew
that it could do it even
with the rank and file.
Because even if the Russians
weren't that happy with how
they did in Georgia, most of
the reasons they weren't happy
we're about combined arms
and the use of technology.
Not about their people being
able to follow order and behave
professionally.
Which, they pretty much did.
So we already
knew-- so, kind of,
my bottom line is I do think
the Russian military's better
than it used to be.
And my guess is it's even
better than it was in Georgia.
But just how good it
is-- Crimea's no test of.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
I have a couple
Russian friends--
they live in this country.
They've been here
for like 15-20 years.
And they're educated--
US universities.
And so whenever something
happens with Russia
I ask them for their opinions.
And basically, when
I asked my friend
what he thought about Crimea
he said, I'm no fan of Putin,
but Russian speakers
there are under threat.
So he's basically, repeating
the same propaganda
that we hear from
Russian television.
OLGA OLIKER: As opposed
to the propaganda
we hear from
American television.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
my question is--
to me that just seems
absurd because I
think that it is propaganda.
And I don't-- I just--
my question's, basically,
is there any legitimacy to that?
Are there-- are
the Russian-- like,
were the Russian speakers
in Crimea ever under threat?
Do we have evidence
of that at all?
OLGA OLIKER: I don't
think they were
under any kind of
physical threat.
I think it was, kind of,
there was this concern
that, oh my God, there are
ultra rightist patrolling
the streets of Kiev--
which there, kind of, were.
And what is this going
to mean for me longer
term that a lot of these groups,
particularly, the ultra right
groups, have said
virulently anti-Russian--
and also, antisemitic,
and I can't
imagine their fond of
the Tatars-- things.
But most people are, kind
of, willing to accept
that the government would not
be dominated by these people.
Now I think that's
still-- it's dangerous.
It's a concern.
But that is very much what
the Russian media, include--
look if you're from Russia, and
you read Russian news sources,
again, you can pick and
choose which ones you read.
Just like in the United
States, you can watch Fox News
or you can watch MSNBC.
And you can here a story
you expect to hear.
There are Russian's
who don't think this--
including in Russia.
They get their news elsewhere.
But it's not that shocking, and
it comes from a grain of truth.
And I've talked
to Ukrainians who
say that they were concerned.
Maybe not concerned
for their lives,
but concerned for the
economy, concerned
about the effects of the
EU Association agreement.
And then again, the [INAUDIBLE].
You know, I said, most people
don't feel under threat,
but some people do.
So you know.
MALE VOICE: 30% is a lot.
OLGA OLIKER: 30% is a lot.
Less than 30, really, but yeah,
it's kind of in the high 20's.
But yeah, it's-- people do.
And it's, you know, some
really feel under threat,
and some think,
maybe threatened.
So it breaks down further,
but there's a nervousness.
And why wouldn't there be,
given what they've been fed?
And I'm nervous about
the ultra right wing
groups in Ukraine's
government, too.
I mean, I think that it's
very important for Ukraine
to find ways that they don't
dominate the discussion.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry-- one is
like manipulating the event,
because they can, like, you
hear both sides of the story.
OLGA OLIKER: Sure, but you
have to look for it, don't you?
I mean I was just-- I was--
I have a Twitter feed, right?
I try to keep the news on
my Twitter feed balanced
from different sources.
But I also know that
I believe some people
and I don't believe others.
I mean, I have a bias
on how I read it.
And I have friends
who watch Fox.
who watch MSNBC.
They just-- the only reason
they would hear the other
is if somebody's pointing
out how silly something is.
I mean, I don't think this
is unique to Russians.
I think Americans do this, too.
I think one of the
effects of, kind of,
this broad access
to information is
we can pick and choose
what information we here.
CHRIS DEFAY: [INAUDIBLE].
You have one back here,
and we'll do one more.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to move
a little bit to the West.
And I haven't heard
much about Europe.
And watching the BBC, they seem
to be pretty light and not very
aggressive in their language.
So what's going on
with them, and what
Europe's thinking about this.
OLGA OLIKER: Crop
story-- sorry, oops.
AUDIENCE: What do [INAUDIBLE]
thinks about this?
OLGA OLIKER: Who do
your so it depends
on what you mean
by Europe, right?
Romanians would really like
F-16s and a lot of US forces.
Missile batteries
would also be nice.
Germans don't, actually, want
to change their energy mix.
And it's going to
be a big hassle.
And if we have to impose
sanctions-- I mean,
God, it's going
to be a big deal.
Why did the Russians
have to do this now?
This is kind of what-- so
you get different views
in different parts of Europe.
And it-- where you stand,
depends on where you sit.
I think there is, in
Europe, a nervousness
about the possibility
of Russia going further.
But it is, kind of,
the story actually
before of there's the people who
are nostalgic for the situation
before the Russians did
this annoying thing.
And then there are people who
are nostalgic for the Cold War.
And probably, the
further West you get,
the more-- they're
nostalgic for how
things were a few months ago.
And the further East you
go-- they've been telling us
all along that the
Russians are dangerous.
We should have paid attention.
So that's how Europe
is looking at it.
But that, kind of, in
terms of going forward,
I think maintaining
a European consensus
on sanctions will be difficult,
particularly, in the West.
Because it does hurt them, too.
Now they can-- they can adjust,
but they don't, necessarily,
want to.
AUDIENCE: So I'm Ukranian, so I,
kind of, care about the topic.
And I want--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I try to stay
away from propaganda,
but what can be done to improve
the situation in Ukraine?
Kind of, have it be stronger.
OLGA OLIKER: Ukraine needs
to have these elections.
And needs to make them as
free and fair as possible.
And to make sure that people
from the East and South
are represented.
It does not, by any means,
have to move to the, sort of,
federalism Russia is suggesting.
But I think direct
election of governors
is a nice move-- as
opposed to having
them appointed from the center.
You know, it does give
people more of a voice.
It is going to need to move
forward on economic reforms.
But it's going to need to do it
in a way that reassures people
who feel they're going
to be hurt by them
that they won't be.
Including-- by offering
some sorts of subsidies,
and so forth.
But to do this, it's going
to need a lot of support
from Europe and the United
States-- and financing.
I mean, we're going
to have bankroll this.
And this creates a real
tension, because how do you
bankroll something like
this, while still holding
these people accountable for
both political and economic
reforms?
You can't keep bankrolling
them if they don't do it.
And for the last
20 years, Ukraine
has been very good at signing
on to things with the EU,
with Russia, with
whoever else and, then,
not following through.
So-- I mean, I think
that will be a challenge.
And it's possible that this
crisis has been sufficient.
That Ukraine's next
government will pull this off.
But it's tough because
the business interests
and the corruption in that
country-- the go so deep.
And most of the people
running for office
are still tied to that.
And their ability to
cut themselves off
from these very lucrative
deals-- it's going to be tough.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I wonder
if there's any known ways
to fight corruption.
Like globally-- or from
inside or from outside.
What-- like, there been places
where it was really corrupt
and some how went clean.
OLGA OLIKER: It's
a long process.
I think the one thing we know
about overcoming corruption
is that it takes
real economic growth.
And it takes time.
And sometimes that time is
not quite generational--
close to it.
Kahka Bendukidze, who's a
former Minister of Economics
in Georgia, said that what
Ukraine needs is three people.
It needs somebody who's
going to jail everyone who
needs to be jailed.
It needs someone
who's going to protect
that person politically.
And then, it needs
somebody else who's
going to protect
the both of them.
So, you know, it's-- I think
that's-- fighting corruption
requires government's making
a decision not to be corrupt
and sticking to it.
It's really difficult to
fight corruption from outside
and, kind of,
impose these rules.
It tends not to work.
CHRIS DEFAY: OK,
thank you very much.
OLGA OLIKER: All right, thanks.